nos dicen que el árbol genealógico
representa la herencia de daltonismo a
lo largo de tres generaciones y aquí
podemos ver que un cuadro representa a
un hombre y un círculo representa a una
mujer si el cuadro está rellenado eso
significa que la persona tiene el rasgo
que en este caso está alto mismo por
ejemplo roberto tiene daltonismo su
fenotipo es daltonismo mientras que a
berta no lo tiene el daltonismo es un
rasgo recesivo ligado al cromosoma x si
barbara espera a otro hijo aquí tenemos
a barbara cuál es la probabilidad de que
sea daltónico los invito a que pause en
el vídeo y vean si pueden resolver vamos
a ver aquí no se están preguntando por
su siguiente hijo cuál es la
probabilidad de que sea daltónico para
eso podemos tratar de conocer los
genotipos de tomás y barber tomás es
hombre aquí tenemos un cuadrado así que
tiene un cromosoma x y un cromosoma ji
ahora el altón ismo es un rasgo recesivo
ligado al cromosoma x
trataré de explicarlo mejor vamos a
decir que se minúscula se refiere a
daltonismo y tal vez podría usarse
mayúscula para identificar el rasgo
dominante que en este caso no es
daltonismo pero para que no se confunda
mejor usar el signo más para indicar que
no hay presencia de daltonismo no hay
daltonismo entonces con tomás su
fenotipo es de alto nismo y como
solamente tiene un cromosoma x en donde
el rasgo de daltonismo está presente
podemos decir que contiene el alelo
recesivo este es el genotipo de tomás
pero que me dicen de barba bueno
barbara tiene dos cromosomas x por ser
mujer y sabemos que los dos cromosomas
no pueden ser se minúscula porque si así
fuera barbara tendría daltonismo pero
entonces como podemos conocer su
genotipo
bueno simplemente podemos estudiar a sus
padres aquí podemos ver que roberto
tiene el mismo genotipo que tomás al
menos con respecto al daltonismo al ser
hombre tiene un cromosoma x y un
cromosoma ye y como tiene daltonismo el
cromosoma x debe de tener el alelo
recesivo de daltonismo por otro lado no
conocemos el genotipo de berta sabemos
que ella es x x tiene dos cromosomas x
pero al igual que barbara los dos
cromosomas no pueden tener el alelo
recesivo porque de ser así el círculo de
berta estaría rellenado pero no sabemos
si ella es portadora o no entonces vamos
a tratar de interpretar el origen de los
cromosomas de barberà uno de sus
cromosomas lo heredó de su padre y el
otro lo heredó de su madre así que como
obtuvo este cromosoma de su padre aquí
podemos ver que su padre solamente tiene
un cromosoma x para dar que es el que
contiene a la ley lo del daltonismo
entonces sí
el cromosoma proviene de su padre debe
de tener el alelo del daltonismo por lo
tanto podemos deducir que el cromosoma
proveniente de su madre no contiene el
alelo del daltonismo porque si fuera así
bárbara sería daltónico pero no lo es
así que aquí tenemos un signo más
este es el alelo dominante y no contiene
el alelo del daltonismo
ahora que ya conocemos los genotipos de
los dos podemos conocer los casos
posibles de su nuevo hijo por ejemplo
tomás puede contribuir con un cromosoma
x que contiene el alelo del daltonismo o
puede contribuir con el cromosoma
mientras que barbara puede contribuir
con un cromosoma x que contenga el alelo
del daltonismo o puede contribuir con el
cromosoma x que no contiene ese alelo
recordemos que barbara exportador con
esto dicho vamos a dibujar el cuadro de
pune en total tenemos cuatro casos
posibles para el genoma de su hijo un
caso sería la combinación del alelo x
proveniente de barberà que contiene el
alelo del alto nismo y el cromosoma x
proveniente de tomás que también
contiene el cromosoma del daltonismo
otra opción es que tenga el cromosoma x
de barberà que contiene el alelo del
daltonismo y el cromosoma 7 tomás
también podría ser que tenga el
cromosoma x que no contiene el a
del daltonismo y el cromosoma
proveniente de tomás que si contiene ese
alelo o podría ser que tenga el
cromosoma x que no contiene el alelo y
el cromosoma ye de su padre así que
tenemos cuatro posibles casos pero en
cuántos de estos escenarios está
presente el alto nismo bueno aquí
tenemos a una mujer con daltonismo ya
que los dos son alelos recesivos
la mujer será daltónico por acá tenemos
a una mujer portadora pero no mostrará
el fenotipo del daltonismo y por acá
tenemos a un hombre con daltonismo sólo
tiene un cromosoma x y ese cromosoma
contiene el alelo del alto nismo y
finalmente aquí tenemos a un hombre que
no presenta daltonismo así que de las
cuatro opciones dos indican que el hijo
o hija puede presentar de alton ismo por
lo tanto 2 de 4 equivale al 50% de
probabilidades de que el hijo o hija
tenga daltonismo
hemos terminado nos vemos en otro vídeo